The struggle against Thanos might have gone
very differently if screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely had gotten their
way.
In an interview with The New York Times, the
pair reveal that they almost introduced a
decades-old Marvel character in Avengers:
Infinity War, one with vast cosmic powers.
In fact, that might even be understating the
case.
The character in question is the multi-dimensional
entity known as the Living Tribunal, and the
scope of its powers over the multiverse are
really quite tremendous.
Unlike nearly every other character in Marvel
lore, the Living Tribunal is a singular entity,
with no alternate counterparts in different
universes.
Instead, it has dominion over the entire Multiverse.
No matter how you slice it, this entity is
kind of a big deal.
The Living Tribunal is usually depicted as
a giant, golden, humanoid figure with three
faces, each one representing a different aspect
of the being: Equity, Necessity, and Vengeance.
The Living Tribunal seeks to maintain balance
and order throughout the entire Multiverse,
and all three of its faces must agree that
an action is necessary before intervening
in the affairs of mere mortals.
However, once it does decide an intervention
is in order, its authority is absolute.
It's all pretty heady stuff, but it's easy
to see why Markus and McFeely toyed with the
idea of throwing such a fascinating character
into the mix for Infinity War.
But seeing as the film and Avengers: Endgame
are already stuffed with plenty of characters,
it's also easy to see why Marvel Studios ultimately
nixed the idea.
Intriguingly, Markus and McFeely suggested
that head honcho Kevin Feige might have another
reason for omitting the character from the
action: Namely, he wants to save it for a
future film.
Asked if there were any characters the duo
wanted for Infinity War and Endgame that they
couldn't have, Markus told The New York Times:
McFeely continued:
The fight on Titan was quite eventful enough,
and the sudden appearance of an as-yet-unseen
golden god with three faces might have totally
thrown moviegoers for a loop.
However, Markus went on to say:
McFeely says then openly worried that they'd
just spoiled a big surprise.
And that's when Markus suggested that the
Living Tribunal could have his very own streaming
show.
McFeely even proposed the show would be similar
to Judge Judy.
But really, that's just silly.
"Are you trying to justify to me the fact
that you're an idiot?"
Perhaps Markus and McFeely did blab a bit
too freely, because we can think of a perfect
vehicle for the Living Tribunal to receive
a proper introduction to the MCU: The Eternals
deals with a race of immortal, superpowered
beings created millions of years ago by the
Celestials and tasked with defending the Earth
from their evil counterparts, the Deviants.
Think about it: an appearance by the Living
Tribunal in The Eternals wouldn't feel out
of place at all, where it could've been a
little jarring if this entity just popped
in to Infinity War to assist the good guys.
Even if they could've used the help...
At any rate, Markus and McFeely clearly have
so many ideas, they couldn't possibly have
all been covered in Infinity War and Endgame,
even though they're two of the biggest event
films of all time.
Here's hoping Endgame isn't their MCU swan
song.
After all, the six films they've written so
far, all three Captain America movies, Thor:
The Dark World, Infinity War, and Endgame,
add up to more than a quarter of the MCU's
entire output.
And all those films pretty much landed right
on the money, no?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.